[Music]
[Applause]
if you were a coach and won the overtime
toss would you take the ball and go for
two if we score or would you kick off
and get the ball second all right let's
bring in brandon staley the chargers
head coach coach i'll start right there
with you you're an analytics guy
strategy wise now with overtime and both
teams get the ball
what do you think you're going to be
leaning towards if you go into overtime
in the postseason
well it's gonna be with you dan
hopefully you can appreciate that date
and flyer helmet in the back of uh this
movie looks pretty um
really good to be with you uh yeah it's
by the way you have to join the list of
john gruden and chuck noll
as
you know university of dayton grads who
went on to win a super bowl so no
pressure there but you need to j you
know jump in uh into that group there
yeah or join you know guys like dan
patrick who have become a sports icon or
starting his own show
pioneer
yeah you know
well that was mcveigh sean mcveigh
sean mcveigh was going to go into the
media you know not yet mcvay claims
dayton through his grandpa i think so
but we're gonna have to look into that a
little bit but um yeah it's i mean
yesterday was a an important day for the
league and there was a lot of really
good discussion i think being a part of
the discussions
you see that the the future of the
league is really important to the people
in it and there was a lot of
um
good dialogue i think healthy discussion
and uh i think that we came to the
conclusion that the postseason was where
really the the change needed to be made
and
i think that as as you saw with the vote
that um you know there was a
really you know significant support for
it so i think that it is going to change
things when you don't have that sudden
death element um i do think there's
going to be some you know different
calculation as you head um into the game
and i think that now when you're
guaranteeing both possessions um you
know which side of the field you're on
hey you know wind you know that sort of
thing knowing that you are going to get
an op um
you know it's just like that it's that
information advantage that you have by
possibly deferring um because you don't
have that sudden death element so uh and
i think the thinking is that if uh you
did go down and score and and kick an
extra point that hey the likelihood of
the second team going down and not going
for two to win it um you know they're
saying is is low but um if you did if it
did end up going you know score pat
score pat that next score would would
finish it and and i think that there was
just a lot of discussion of hey past
this initial period
hey then what's going to happen is there
is there's still a time element which
there will be you're going to flip the
field and just head in a different
direction so uh it was it was a good
resolution and and now we're uh we're
finally headed towards something are you
okay with the overtime rule in the
regular season
yes you know i think the
no our position with the chargers was
that the rules are already different in
the postseason
as opposed to the regular season um you
know in the regular season you can end
in a tie post season you can't so the
rules are already different and and so
we support uh we support the things
staying the way um it is in in the
regular season what was your initial
reaction when you learned that tyreek
hill was no longer in the afc west
yes one of those really significant
moves that was sort of the theme of this
offseason
you know i think defending the guy over
the course of these you know however
long i've been in the nfl um he's
definitely a dangerous player one of the
most i think dangerous weapons that's
ever played in the national football
league uh but at the same time one of
the most dangerous players to ever play
in the nfl uh is the guy who was
throwing it to him so
that guy's still that guy's still there
um they've got a team which is the
reason why they've been to the afc
championship game two three or four
years in a row and so it was a monster
move for sure um i've got full respect
for him he's still in the afc so uh
we're still gonna be running into that
guy um but uh you know i think that you
know kansas city's resume speaks for
itself and the competition i think dan
what you're seeing is it's as fierce as
it's ever been in the league which is
good for the league i wonder it felt
like the defensive strategy last year
against kansas city was keep everything
in front of you
no home run plays and really you would
give mahomes
10 12 15 yards you're just not going to
give him that opportunity to break
something big and it seemed to frustrate
him
is the league do you think that was a
kind of a philosophy there group
philosophy going against kansas city
well i think everyone you know has been
searching for for several years a
formula that can work for them um and
there aren't too many good ones that's
for sure uh but i think
you know you just gotta take into
consideration who they have over there
uh who's throwing the football and and
kind of how he plays and then who those
weapons are he's thrown to i mean
starting with tyrique and travis you
know those are two of the best players
at their positions in the history of the
game and kind of how they play off
schedule with pat who's such a dangerous
thrower on the move and he's accurate in
the deep part of the field on the move
um and you know kind of the miraculous
really isn't that big of a miracle with
him because he does it all the time uh
and then they just got a lot of team
speed elsewhere outside of those three
players so i think um that certainly was
a strategy but i think that's probably
too uh too vague of a way of describing
it um because you still got to be
connected with these guys if you're
playing zone um these guys are you know
he's going to throw for 80 to 90 percent
he'll throw for 450 or 500 um you may it
may take him longer to score but he's
still going to score so you you have to
still decide how you're going to play
the game and um but again that's why
what makes them such a challenging cover
what did you learn in your first year
that might surprise me
i think that in my first year i think
the way i describe it is that everything
was happening for the first time all the
time
so if you can imagine that every day
something's happening you for the first
time um and i think that a lot of people
would say like hey is that is that
stressful you know and i would say
my response to that was i i felt like it
was energizing because i knew how good i
needed to be every single day in order
to make those improvements and
i think that i got a lot better from the
first time i think i interviewed with
you when i got hired to to this
interview
i know how much i've improved and i know
how much better i am in my own game um
but that first year went by fast
everybody said it it would and i think
for that reason that i mentioned that
that was a big contributing factor
but also you're getting in front of the
media after a tough loss whereas when
you are a coordinator
you don't have to talk to the media
what's that like you lose a game gather
your thoughts and then go get peppered
with questions
well i think it was like when i was
playing at quarterback you kind of have
that responsibility if it doesn't go
down you know and so i think that having
played that position that that kind of
uniquely prepares you growing up being a
quarterback and a point guard uh you're
kind of faced when it doesn't go down
that everyone's looking at you so um i
think that um there was you know that
finality when you lose in the nfl i
think um being in the nfl you see it you
see
uh and everyone talks about it that way
but i think being the head coach and
knowing that
hey you're responsible for a lot a lot
of people who forget forget you know um
the game itself but just the people that
were playing in the game and the people
your fans who this means so much for um
you're accountable for that and it's
it's a great responsibility and that's
why when you go in front of the media
after a tough game
you know you have to be on you know to
make sure that um you do your best to
explain what happened and to the best of
your ability and that's what i tried to
do this year
i asked about your impressions when
tyree kill left the afc west your uh
initial reaction when russell wilson
joined the afc west
yeah i mean competition is fierce and i
think that um you know i've played
against russell a lot in my nfl career
watched him uh throughout his whole
career i mean going back to nc state
wisconsin um you know he's he's one of
the tremendous players at that position
in uh in the nfl and uh when i was with
the rams we had to face him three times
in one season and and twice in three
weeks uh at the end of the season so uh
it's just again it's it's special for
the league uh and and he's one of those
players that plays you know one of the
most important positions in sports so uh
i think it it's going to bring out the
best in everybody for sure
does sean mcvay rub it in
that he's got a super bowl ring does he
just
you know does he send you uh a text or
something or when he sees you hey i want
you to address me as super bowl winning
coach anything like that
no
sean's too uh too humble to do that and
then he knows better than to do that uh
but um no he he would never do something
like that because he the game you know
how you do things matters to him
um
he's gotta have fun with you though
brandon no he wouldn't do that he
wouldn't go there um because uh you know
we played them this year so uh
you know um but um
no sean uh sean deserves everything that
he that he's
achieved including this year he was
fantastic he did a really good job
coaching that team
that's what i told him you know i just
thought i was like i thought you did a
really good job coaching your team
because
people talk about the end and kind of
their players who they joined up with
but there was a stretch there in the
middle where i don't think anyone was
predicting that the rams were going to
make it to victory lane and that's the
sign of an organization that um
that's that's built to last to be able
to respond to a tough stretch and that's
what they did
who do you get mistaken for
man damn that that
i don't know if i was ready for that one
um
[Music]
i don't know that
well you're in la i mean did you ever
been mistaken identity for an actor
uh i don't know i've gotten some johnny
knoxville comps
[Laughter]
uh you know there was like a a time
there um you know i kind of you know and
i'm the same age as matt weiner uh you
know former quarterback uh
you know but um those are two names that
have been thrown out there in the past i
don't know how accurate they are um and
then you know throughout the year i was
getting pepper with these questions
about this ted lasso guy so um i haven't
watched that show yet but i'm told that
i need to so amy and i may join up with
that show here soon i kind of see peter
brady from the brady bunch
you know what dan now that you mentioned
that i've heard about that and again
that was kind of before my time
uh which probably dates me a little bit
on the youthful side but i didn't join
up with that show as a young kid so well
if you google peter brady you might go
okay i okay he's got a point it's not
it's not an insult it's not an insult uh
that was a successful show yes it was
yes it was uh and johnny knoxville i
could see that you even have the the
voice kind of raspy in there i could see
that get those glasses on i could see
that
maybe bring johnny knoxville to practice
johnny had a great run man he's still
doing it yes he is got a lot of respect
for that guy hey great to talk to you
enjoy the off-season good luck in the
draft and uh always great to visit with
you thanks dan for having me that's
brandon staley chargers head coach